[Music]
okay so all the stuff going on right now
the biggest thing that I hear from
people because there's two camps of
people one is I want to be as informed
as possible I want to have all the
frontline information and the other camp
of people is like damn I can't go
anywhere without hearing about this and
it gives me anxiety because I feel like
there's no safe place like a normal to
return to I like even their favorite
shows their favorite podcasts their
favorite everything is talking about it
because it's really hard not to talk
about it and I get it cuz like we're
here right now and like you probably
tune in to JK all the time and like we
talked about it
but for a lot of people they're like I
wish there was just like one of my
favorite things that just like focused
on like regular life like was just like
back like everything is normal like get
back to regular business you know and so
I was thinking about that a lot because
I'm like yeah I guess for me I haven't
been getting a lot of anxiety because
one I already work from home too
I already have a lot of hobbies that I
do alone so I I have a safe space like a
normal where I'm like oh I have a closet
full of crafts that I do
you've already been living the
quarantine life yeah yeah so it doesn't
feel that off to me like my schedule and
my life doesn't feel very rocked but
there are a lot of people who never
worked from home like there they're like
this is completely off of my normal
routine yeah and like their whole worlds
are completely shifted and so I was just
trying to I was they may opened my eyes
up to like that not everybody is just
like carrying on as usual obviously and
I was wondering like what do you guys do
like what's your like one routine item
or normal thing that you keep doing that
kind of grounds you I have a really big
thing because I saw this on a tweet and
I think this like as much as I hate
Twitter like [ __ ] hate Twitter I hate
that site cow man fuels my hate but I
saw this one tweet that was really
important because when I first started
freelancing like almost like practically
like in college and I was I started
freelancing and stuff I didn't
understand like cuz at first you're like
oh I get to work from home this is
[ __ ] dope and then you just stay in
your pajamas and you just like a roll
out of it or whatever
in the light of the day and then you
just like you know it's kind of like
slide in the computer you like check
Facebook and all that stuff and you're
like I guess I'll get around to working
on stuff and then you do all that sort
of stuff six hours later it really wears
on you though because you don't have
that separation - and for me my
computers like is in my room - like I
have my room and my work kind of area on
one side of my bed and so I'm like
laying in my bed and I can see my
computer
and I can see my work and so I think
it's really important for all the people
that have never worked from home before
still set like a routine like still wake
up at the same time that you are like
roughly the same time that you would be
going to work like don't wake up like
five hours later like wake up and
roughly the same time still get dressed
still clean yourself up still like do
all the normal like things like
definitely change there's no work yeah
because that gets you in the line
employee yeah change your clothes super
super important as comfortable as PJs
are like change into something like you
know that you would you know be going to
work in or at least presentable yeah
something like that but not that you
sleep in but not that you sleep in and
then then do your work and then when you
take your shower you change in your PJs
again you can turn off and then you can
do whatever the hell else you would
usually do after you got home or
separation yes
separation is super important I didn't
understand that I got super depressed
and super burnout because I didn't
understand that for like a couple years
until I figured out like oh this is like
how a healthy person like works from
home yeah cuz yeah even though it's like
it's very convenient when you're
freelance and you work from home it's
still really important to
compartmentalize like your life I think
for me it wasn't so much like the work
and life balance I think for for me and
Geo like our biggest like I guess
hardship in our relationship was the
bits and comedy part so it was almost
like we were cast mates and then home
cast mates yeah the characters didn't
care there's no more home yeah there's
no romance it just constantly cast me to
cast mates cast mates in this obviously
that was like something I was really
hard for us to do it but that and
speaking what Nicki's talking about I
think the one thing that brings me back
to normalcy is they're working out in
the morning so I went to the gym and I
just grabbed a couple pieces of
equipment like we all all the gym staff
was like well no one's gonna be using
this because gyms are shut down in LA so
we all just took off uses equipment to
go home so they'd only use our games or
whatever and so I think being able to
just work
out in the morning kind of like get out
like what me and Joe caught a Wiggles
you know just like trainer ass off a
little bit then I can go back to to the
day and it just helps me like calm the
anxiety and everything down even though
like I'm not very anxious person
it just helps it grounds you centers
yeah takes that edge off find find your
Center since I found working out I need
it more yeah I used to need it back in
my 20s cuz I used to work out all the
time in my twenties but I lost that when
I got sad for a while and getting back
to that like needing to work out it
feels so good
I think after you we're talking about
all that Ryan I'm like you know what
maybe that's why over the years I've
been feeling even more and more like
even though like different aspects of my
life I do feel good and like better than
I did before but overall I still have
like this consistent like flattened line
feeling of like I don't know what to do
with my life right I don't to do with my
day I'm like okay well there's things I
should do that but everything just feels
like you know nothing feels like goals
yes checkmarks because you can also have
like goals all the time like you can't
constantly be that person or sick I need
to call for everything all the time like
some people can I don't know I can't I
can't I personally can't yeah like I
need to I need to have a time to like do
that because otherwise like I'm just
constantly stressed out about all the
things and I feel guilty too like
sometimes I'll be trying to play video
games or something and then the this is
legal I've recently got back into video
games because of nothing else to do a
lot of good will have steam just [ __ ]
went nuts
yeah dude hear that steam and Blizzard
[ __ ] all the accounts or all the like
servers keep on like shutting off
because there's too many people
accessing ones listeners are crazy man
blue
form of internets yeah but yeah it's
like I would feel guilty playing a game
for 30 minutes when before and like high
school and nothing else do aside from
homework and stuff I would like play for
like five hours and I'd not feel like a
thing I felt accomplished yeah can you
beat the level yeah but I didn't feel
that once I had work to do but now that
I've like I don't have like a whole lot
of extra stuff to our places to go
things to do I'm like oh I can enjoy
video games again like stuff like that
is like separating it all out like right
now with the whole house situation like
I'm trying to fit like every day it's
like little jobs here and there it's
like oh wait we got to make sure we get
this done or we got to make sure we get
that done and then once they get done
I'm like oh that feels good but then for
some reason I constantly have like this
guilt of like I didn't do enough or I
get overwhelmed with like how much I
have to do it oh my great uh just [ __ ]
today I'm just gonna be in bed all day
because it's just too overwhelming and
like I don't know I don't know how to
manage my expectations to is I feel like
you've been telling me like like if
we're moving we're gonna do all the the
construction and hiring contractors to
come and do this and do that we're
installing that piece on this piece
buying this piece behind that piece yeah
and you really you say things like if I
don't do it as soon as we move in I'll
never get it done we're gonna live here
for the next ten years and that's not
gonna be done and I feel like that
expectation again do it all at once is
very overwhelming that's sure I think
you just embrace the fact that it's
gonna take time to get everything done
yeah yeah that's been a hard thing to
balance for me too cuz like I can easily
slip into lazy mode and so I think I
developed this like crazy schedule and
and like planning so that I don't slip
into that because once I'm there I could
take a while to like get out of and and
then but now because I've been doing
this mode for so many years of like
can't stop working can't stop working or
else I will fall apart yeah I realized
yeah I had like crazy gut problems and
stress problems and stress causes so
much physical health repercussions than
I ate then I never ever knew it dude it
affects your mental health it affects
your physical health it affects so much
that I had no idea about so now it's
been interesting trying to incorporate
me time like free time time nothing time
where it's like you can't do any no work
I still sometimes feel like I have to
earn it where I'm like okay if you work
for three hours straight then you earn a
one hour break and then you got to work
for five hours straight
thank you break no I'm curious oh I
meditate I go for a walk now well going
for a walk actually has been something
that I I need
tick tock is not that's up that's work
it's like a search it's a more toxic
thing yeah it's more well you can get
sucked into it work yeah but we're going
on a walk it gives you endorphins and
like it I find I gotta get my best ideas
when I'm on a walk like it just gets you
into that flow state where you're
completely present and that's that's
something new like cuz you're talking
about doing something that makes you
feel like it's normal times yeah me I
mean I guess like still counts cuz Isaac
and I like the three of us we've been
bike riding around our new community
yeah I've been like so call me and like
my thighs are sore I'm like oh my name
is the grapes or yeah yeah and then like
I'm like this is what normal people do I
would never do and it took all of this
to have been for me to be like yeah
let's go out door squeak let's go and
right away that's been nice yeah for me
I don't know I feel like something that
helps keep me grounded even without all
the [ __ ] that's happening I think it's
always been cooking like just not having
food having groceries and like I kind of
just having me time because like when I
cook I don't I do it by myself I don't
talk to anyone I'm not I'm not a talking
kind of person I don't need to like get
words out all the time I can just kind
of sit there my own thoughts and just
just do something and you see they're
like tinker with something yeah and my
cooking is that for me I like to smell
like the the results of it and they get
to like on like a reward at the end yeah
so like and so in this time it's like
it's even more important I feel like to
like make sure I'm groceries and you
have to be able to do that and light and
by doing that you're not necessarily
needing to go on Twitter and remind
yourself your stress I think any time so
creating something which cooking is yeah
you know we're like you have your you're
kind of zoned into it for a little bit
at the end you see like a visible
results there
I like that creative process yeah I
would love to feel that way about
cooking but I always feel like it needs
hot sauce so it's like what's the point
of cooking yeah only Indian food listen
if I could [ __ ] cook it I would all
of this food turns into Tabasco suka
masala every single day that or that or
any kind of Thai food Thai foods my
favorite thing so but I just don't think
I can do it very well
I think you can I think following
directions and just like practice so bad
directions of measurement practice and
messing up that's the thing I still I
made something super salty the other two
days in a row no but I'm saying like
whatever you made probably better than
anything I can make I guarantee it
that's right so that's why you saw sauce
so but then I like the hot sauce I think
I get dopamine from hot sauce like I
think you probably did
that's a grounds you yeah maybe that's
what it is I answer to your question
that stay grounded is to find your
version you're a healthy version of
dopamine yeah hey would maybe you
described earlier of me on skype with my
bud and we're right in the movie that's
my dopamine like just getting the
[ __ ] yeah play I like to play but
that's my whole thing and so yeah being
in the room with my boys and getting the
[ __ ] around that's my [ __ ] man so yeah
and then hold yourself accountable to
that to where you're like well
technically this is my job
yes so then like you know let's play a
little brings you joy and then you
create something exactly so so hopefully
and by the way those of you watching
this right now you like why don't do
that yeah well now's a good time yeah
it's the most productive time maybe of
your life that you'll ever get so it's
time to [ __ ] do it
you might even just get sent money in
the mail thousands of dollars perhaps
perhaps one thousand dollars whatever it
is but you're about to get paid for the
[ __ ] you're doing so make it worth your
while like treat it like a job right now
and maybe it will become one later yeah
[Music]
[Music]